韓國美妝產業 K-beauty 相信大家都不陌生，很多產品真的做得很好。但你知道嗎，他們之所以能崛起，背後竟然是借鑒了台積電的模式？
等等，台積電是半導體晶圓代工，美妝是保養品跟彩妝，這兩個產業根本八竿子打不著吧？怎麼會扯在一起？這聽起來有點出乎意料。
對啊，這就是最讓我詫異的地方。一般來說，美妝品牌都是從研發、生產、行銷到銷售一手包辦，講究品牌故事和獨家配方。誰會想到把核心生產外包出去？
確實，這與一般美妝品牌的經營邏輯很不一樣。如果把生產交給別人，要怎麼確保品質跟獨特性？這樣會不會降低自己的品牌價值？
其實，這正是 K-beauty 成功的關鍵。他們透過專業分工，把產品研發和製造交給像 Kolmar 這樣的 ODM（原廠委託設計製造）公司。這些公司自己不擁有品牌，只專注在研發和代工。
喔，所以就像台積電只負責晶圓製造，不推出自己的晶片一樣。那這些 ODM 公司具體怎麼做的？是只要接到訂單就生產嗎？
不只是接到訂單。原文有提到，這些公司能以「前所未有的速度」將新產品推向市場。這代表他們有很強的研發能力，能快速反應市場趨勢，甚至創造趨勢。
速度快是優勢，但我還是有點疑問。這樣做，品牌方等於是「輕資產營運」？把最花錢的廠房、設備都省下來了？
沒錯，就是輕資產。品牌方可以把更多資源投入到行銷、品牌塑造和市場拓展上，而不用擔心龐大的研發和生產成本。這也讓他們可以更大膽地嘗試新產品。
這樣聽起來，等於是把高風險、高投入的製造環節「外包」出去了。那如果我是新創美妝品牌，我可以怎麼利用這個模式？
如果你是新創，就可以把有限的資金集中在產品概念和行銷上，找一家可靠的 ODM 夥伴來負責研發和生產。這樣你就能以更快的速度推出產品，測試市場反應。
這點我是信了，因為原文確實點出他們能「快速將新產品推向市場」。這種模式，對於資金沒那麼雄厚的新創公司來說，或許真的是一個彎道超車的機會。
對一般上班族來說，我覺得這個概念也很有啟發。工作中我們常常覺得什麼都要自己做，從頭到尾負責。但或許，我們可以想想自己核心的競爭力在哪裡。
你的意思是，把一些非核心，或是自己不擅長的工作，試著「外包」出去？例如，尋找專門的工具或資源來協助？
嗯，其實可以換個角度思考，在專案管理上，是不是有些環節可以更有效率地協作，把一些「代工」的機會讓給更專業的同事或團隊，讓大家都能專注在自己最擅長的事情上。
我懂了，就像 K-beauty 把研發製造交給專業 ODM，而品牌方則專注在洞察市場和行銷。這種分工合作，或許能讓整體效率更高，而且能更快地應對變化。
沒錯。所以，無論你是想創業、管理團隊，甚至只是在日常工作中，想想自己或團隊最能創造價值的地方在哪裡，然後如何有效地與他人協作，或許都能帶來意想不到的收穫。
聽起來，這好像也提醒了我們，有時候跳脫既有的框架，從看似不相關的領域學習，或許能找到新的解決方案。